Summer is almost here.
And whether you're hitting the beach or the pool,...
...healthy recipes will keep you cool and fit this season.
Hi guys, I'm Krystin Goodwin with Buzz60,...
...and here are a few low-cal poolside recipes to stay in shape this summer.
Add flavor to your day with these low-cal strawberry Popsicles.
Take one cup of plain, nonfat Greek yogurt,...
...half a cup of vanilla protein powder and whip in a bowl.
Take strawberries, a tablespoon of coconut oil, one tablespoon of stevia...
...and half a cup of almond milk and mix into a blender.
Add the blend to the whipped Greek yogurt and protein,...
...then pour the mix into a Popsicle container with sticks...
...and freeze for a sweet protein pop.
Or try this refreshing lemon-lime soda.
Take two cups of carbonated water and half a cup of lemon and lime juice,...
...add one tablespoon of stevia, mix and garnish with lemon or lime.
So keep cool this season with healthy snacks.
Nutritious can be this delicious.
Buzz60, now you know, pass it on.